you may have heard that some people down
in the prep school wrote some racial
slurs on some message boards this week
Lieutenant General J Silverio had some
fighting words for thousands of Cadets
faculty and senior officers at the Air
Force Academy in Colorado if you're
outraged by those words then you're in
the right place those words had been
discovered by five black students
outside their rooms you should be
outraged not only as an airman but as a
human being the Air Force Academy posted
the remarks to YouTube on Thursday so
far they've been viewed more than half a
million times we would also be tone-deaf
not to think about the backdrop of
what's going on in our country things
like charlottesville in Ferguson the
protests in the NFL that's why we have a
better idea the idea he said is the
power of diversity the power that we
come from all walks of life that we come
from all parts of this country that we
come from all races we come from all
backgrounds gender all makeup all
upbringing and makes us that much more
powerful the Air Force superintendent
even asked cadets to record part of the
message on their cell phones to make
sure it isn't forgotten if you can't
teach someone from another gender
whether that's a man or a woman with
dignity and respect
then you need to get out and if you
can't treat someone from another race or
a different color skin with dignity and
respect
then you need to get out this has
resonated foreign why'd this speech very
powerful and I saw a lot of comments we
need more like the lieutenant general